c'est venu c'est venu me chercher parce
que il y a des choses qui aura été
faites dans sauvetage natif grâce à
Montréal puis je me dis qu'aujourd'hui
ça aurait jamais dû arriver c'est que ça
[Musique]
le pompier pierre
lac dans les rapides de la Chine faut-il
blâmer la force des courants sûrement
mais s'il y avait autre chose
[Musique]
on est poignée avec les on s'entend des
bateaux qui sont pas tout à fait ce
qu'on a besoin
se trouvait Pierre Lacroix il y a
peut-être des problèmes avec ce bateau
qu'on a tenté de cacher de même qu'avec
l'ensemble de la gestion des sauvetages
nautiques un enregistrement confidentiel
un rapport qui était disparu mais qu'on
a retrouvé et le témoignage précieux de
pompiers vont nous éclairer c'est une
question de temps vocale un accident
avec ce bateau-là
c'est une des preuves qui les pompiers
ont pas été écoutés ici Marie monte
Denis bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
je suis vraiment raconté mon histoire
pour que les choses changent parce que
ça fait plusieurs années que toujours le
même problème
je pense que le fait que j'ai plus de
pop-up c'est une des preuves qui les
pompiers ont pas été écoutés
[Musique]
pour le dernier salut du premier Lacroix
salut madame
[Musique]
au nom de la caserne au syndicap on vous
remercie d'être venu aujourd'hui en
honneur de pierre
la mort soudaine du pompier Pierre
Lacroix le 17 octobre 2021 a créé une
immense onde de choc mon père c'était
quelqu'un qui aurait donné sa chemise
pour n'importe qui qui avait besoin
d'aide et c'est vraiment un des piliers
la caserne 64 parce que tout le monde il
comptait sur lui il m'avait dit que
quand la cloche a sonne la switch de sa
vie à Thomas off puis l'œil devient
pierre le pompier il est plus Pierre la
croix il devient un pompier puis le
match jump c'est d'aller sauver les gens
qui sont dans le besoin
[Musique]
mais ce décès tragique a également
réveillé une colère contenue depuis
longtemps quelques mois après les
funérailles un lanceur d'alerte nous
contactent pour nous faire découvrir une
face cachée du service de sécurité
incendie de Montréal c'est juste en face
de ma demande moi de l'intérieur de ma
cuisine puis de ma salade
c'est ça ici que je vois ce que je vois
ici là c'est l'endroit où est-ce que
l'intervention assez déroulée
c'est la première fois que je reviens
17 octobre
[Musique]
a été pompier et pratiquement toute sa
vie il a commencé à lâcher en 1989 et a
exercé ce métier pendant plus de 30 ans
dont 8 en tant qu'instructeur puis de
2011 à 2015 il a été responsable du
sauvetage nautique et sur glace au
service d'incendie de la Ville de
Montréal que la formation elle
entraînement les bateaux mais de la
façon de travailler avec les
embarcations l'équipement et de
s'occuper aussi d'un groupe
d'instructeurs qui forment les gens à
l'interne avec un caractère était décédé
c'est sûr que ça m'a fait quelque chose
ça me fait encore de quoi parce que
c'est quelqu'un de très proche mais
c'est aussi parce que je me suis occupé
du sauvetage nautique
en entrant dans l'univers des pompiers
nous ne nous doutions pas des
difficultés que nous allions rencontrer
les rescapés au premier chef ce qui
était à bord de l'embarcation avec
Pierre Lacroix ont tous refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue
[Musique]
nous avons reconstitué la soirée du 17
octobre en partie grâce au communication
radio que nous avons obtenu
[Musique]
et à partir du récit écrit d'un pompier
présent ce soir-là et qui a eu
connaissance de tous les faits il a
requis l'anonymat il n'est pas autorisé
à nous transmettre de l'information
l'histoire du bateau numéro 18 64 celui
à bord duquel se trouvait Pierre Lacroix
commence vers 19h10 à environ 8 km en
amont et rapide de la Chine à Montréal
des plaisanciers sont en panne au milieu
du fleuve la centrale 9 1 reçoit un
signalement quatre pompiers répondent à
la Perrine
le 18 64 se met en route sans perte de
temps à pleine vitesse
l'embarcation continue à dériver il fait
noir l'éclairage est important
ce soir-là le courant est deux fois plus
fort que d'habitude un décompte est
donné dans 4 minutes le bateau passe des
rapides l'urgence d'agir est présent
les ondes sont inondées d'information le
décompte continue dans 2 minutes
l'embarcation passe très rapide le 18 64
est à plein régime impossible d'aller
plus vite
ensuite le poste de commandement averti
dans une minute l'embarcation passe très
rapide le 18 64 aperçoit l'embarcation
la lumière est dessus le contact est
fait la victime lance un câble mêlé aux
personnel le 18 64 attache l'embarcation
nananée car la vague est derrière les
victimes
pierre dit de ne pas tâcher le câble
trop serré car si un problème le 18 64
va pouvoir détacher le câble pour pas se
faire emporter avec l'embarcation le 18
64 commence à remorquer l'embarcation le
18 64 tente de sortir de là mais leur
bateau tombe en cavitation panne de
moteur leur bateau tombe statique le
comme se brise il y a un contact entre
les deux embarcations
un peu d'eau entre sur le devant du
bateau en une fraction de seconde leur
bateau Charlie
le Made est donné le personnel du 18 64
se fait emporter par les ratés
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui savaient des choses
puis je me dis qu'aujourd'hui ça aurait
jamais dû arriver c'est que ce temps-là
le problème c'est que dénoncer au
service de sécurité incendie de Montréal
le Sim comporte son lot de risque c'est
difficile de dénoncer un problème au
service incendie parce que souvent on va
confondre amélioration versus
revendications
c'est encore plus vrai si un pompier
parle à des journalistes pour ce
reportage une quarantaine de personnes
dont plusieurs pompiers ont collaboré
avec nous et ceux qui ont accepté de
témoigner nous ont demandé de changer
leur apparence leur voix et leur noms
vous craignez réellement qu'il y ait des
sanctions ou des mesures disciplinaires
qui vous sont imposés
c'est clair autant du côté de la ville
que du côté du syndicat on parle pas
médias
avant sa retraite Benoît Martel a goûté
à la médecine du cime quand il a remis
en question des façons de faire à
l'interne je sais que je te dérange
jamais
dérangeant moi je voulais que ça
fonctionne puis je voulais surtout que
ça soit sécurisé
vers où était la porte du nautique
et bien qu'un problème bien connu de
plusieurs pompiers depuis des années et
demeurer irrésolu quand là maintenant la
tempête elle a commencé à descendre là
on a fait ok ça c'était quoi les enjeux
qu'est-ce qui aurait pu mener à cet
événement là de mon père place la
question du bateau de se cliquer ces
bateaux là ça fait des années que mon
père il disait oh il est encore brisé
pas c'était pas les humains qui étaient
sur le bateau mais c'était l'équipement
qui était censé les garder en sécurité
là possiblement le problème
au retour est-ce qu'on a ignoré des
signaux d'alarme
c'est le troisième bateau là qui savait
je me dis qu'aujourd'hui ça aurait
jamais
on peut comprendre que bateau éprouve
des difficultés en haute tumultueux mais
vous allez voir que les mésaventures du
Hammerhead ont commencé en eau pas mal
plus calme
[Musique]
au lendemain du tragique décès du
pompier Lacroix peu d'informations
filtres sur les circonstances de
l'accident celui-là et les précédents
qui virait à l'envers troisième pour le
premier on le savait
le bateau est
lorsque je suis devenu chef de cette
spécialité-là il y a eu des incidents
avec ces bateaux là c'est certain que
moi j'ai levé la main en disant mais là
c'est bateau là ils sont ils ont pas
changé
[Musique]
Eric la mer un papier retraité était à
bord du premier bateau qui a chaviré il
a longuement hésité avant de nous parler
il nous a finalement donné rendez-vous
au port de Montréal pour monter à bord
d'un bateau qui nous conduira sur les
lieux de l'accident nous tombons par
hasard sur l'embarcation des pompiers
c'est le fameux Hammerhead c'est dans un
bateau comme celui-ci que Pierre Lacroix
prenait place en octobre 2021 une
embarcation choisie par le Sim
c'est un bateau avec une coque en V
rigide équipée d'une turbine pour
pouvoir aller dans les rapides il est
muni de moteur diesel importé un seul
une embarcation qui à l'époque avait
aussi la particularité d'avoir une porte
sur le côté un peu comme sur ces images
pour faciliter la récupération de
victimes à l'eau une demande du Sim
[Musique]
nous avons retrouvé un des pompiers qui
ont été consultés pour choisir le bateau
Sylvain Ricard était instructeur à
l’époque il n'avait pas de pouvoir
décisionnel mais plusieurs sources nous
indiquent que la direction se fait à lui
ce qu'il ne nie pas il trouvait très
utile l'ajout de la porte
le constructeur pour résoudre tous des
problèmes mais donc vous vous donnez
votre avis là-dessus
c'est à peu près ici que le chavira a eu
lieu
le 1er mai 2009 le Sim vient de mettre
en service sa toute nouvelle flotte de
bateau de sauvetage les pompiers de la
caserne 15 se mettent à l'eau à la
hauteur de Pointe-aux-Trembles dans
l'est de Montréal pour suivre leur
première formation à bord du Hammerhead
s dans l'eau puis ce matin-là on a eu un
premier volet théorique pour après la en
début d'après-midi aller faire un volet
pratique
nous avons obtenu le document original
de la formation d'une source
confidentielle on y vantait notamment sa
grande stabilité ainsi que les mérites
du plancher soi-disant au taux drainant
alors hier il y avait des drains
spécialement qu'on vivait l'embarcation
à un clin d'œil sont assez placés pour
mettre un peu d'eau à l'intérieur face
au vent puis on ouvert la porte on a
fait entrer une portion d'eau mais
rapidement
le l'embarcation c'est mis à être
déstabilisé du côté de la porte avec
l'eau qui rentrait de plus en plus
l'embarcation semble vouloir vraiment
tanguer donc on
se met le pied sur les bords pour
pouvoir sauter à l'eau puis dans les
secondes suivantes l'embarcation nous
suit chavir sur la coque
mes partenaires se trouvent sous le
bateau au moment où il y a sauté la
coque chaviré au-dessus de lui
nous à la surface on le cherche on
l'appelle
le finalement il ressurgit après une
vingtaine de secondes à notre grand
soulagement
ce scénario d’horreur ou des pompiers
restent pris sous l'embarcation et
semblable à celui du chavirment de 2021
deux des quatre membres de l'équipage se
sont retrouvés sous le bateau renversé
l'un d'eux a réussi à s'extirper de la
coque
mais Pierre Lacroix lui est resté coincé
[Musique]
quand vous avez entendu parler de
l'accident de Pierre Lacroix la mort de
Pierre Lacroix du chavirment du bateau
qu'est-ce que vous vous êtes dit
c'est sûr qu'il y a j'ai eu beaucoup de
colère puis de
tristesse puis de désolation
il embarcation depuis le début
et toujours la même embarcation avait
ses limitations c'est particularités
faiblesses
le Bureau de la sécurité des transports
le BST un organisme fédéral indépendant
amener une enquête après le chavirment
de 2009 et il a relevé des problèmes
avec le bateau son rapport est très
clair notamment concernant la fameuse
porte elle ne satisfait pas et par une
marge importante aux exigences
d'étanchéité
le seuil de la porte David au moins 200
mm de la ligne de flataison de l'eau
alors qui était juste 60 et 15 mm donc
ça permet plus d'eau que prévu à rentrer
mais le sème lui voit les choses
autrement dans un rapport interne sur le
chavirment dont nous avons obtenu copie
le Sim conclut nous ne pouvons mettre en
cause la fiabilité de l'embarcation dans
le chavirment de l'embarcation 18-15
pour le Sim c'est sans équivoque
l'incident est directement lié à une
erreur humaine et non au mauvais
fonctionnement d'un élément de
l'embarcation
pour en arriver à ces conclusions le
Sims appuie sur plusieurs témoignages
dont celui de Sylvain Ricard
souvenez-vous c'est lui qui faisait
partie du comité qui demandait qu'on
ajoute une porte au bateau il est monté
en grade et devenu chef aux opérations
il assure n'avoir jamais enseigné les
manœuvres qui ont mené au chat virement
comment on résout le problème on met une
board il y en aura plus de problèmes
selon ce pompier voilà un bon exemple de
contradiction entre la position et les
actions de son employeur même si le Sim
ne voit aucun problème avec le bateau il
leur donne que toutes les portes soient
boulonnées et condamnées les Hammerhead
retombe à l'eau mais là on a une
embarcation de sauvetage qui passe à
raison d'être parce qu'essayer d'ici une
personne par dessus un framboise de 2.5
pieds c'est pratiquement impossible
mais le plus étonnant de cette histoire
nous l'apprenons en contactant un
technicien en architecture navale
embauché par le ciment en 2006 pour
évaluer le Hammerhead avant même que les
bateaux soient livrés ils voyaient déjà
le défaut qui sera relevé plus tard par
le BST il l'avait même dénoncé
est un certainement pas confortable à ce
qui va la récupération d'un malheur
c'est avec ce temps par question là qui
était équipé avec cette porte là parce
que une première gorgée ils vont se
faire peur puis le bateau vache virer
Jean-Claude lorrain voyait très bien le
problème que pouvait constituer la
navigation avec une porte ouverte mais
il n'oubliera pas de sitôt l'accueil
qu'on lui a réservé
[Musique]
on a un inspecteur de Transport Canada
qui nous dit que le bateau est conforme
aux normes de Transport Canada
[Musique]
que la porte est traitée dans ce dossier
là ça n'empêche pas le service de
sécurité incendie de Montréal d'acheter
les Hammerhead après avoir été chercher
la vie d'un autre consultant qui lui
donne le feu vert
le Sim octobre
la compagnie rosboro de Halifax nous
avons tracé le représentant de rosbero
Québec à l'époque
est-ce possible que les ajustements ou
les modifications le sur-mesure qu'on a
fait pour reprendre vos termes est
affecté la stabilité du bateau
certifiés par Transport Canada mais les
normes n'exigent pas que la stabilité du
bateau soit testée en conditions réelles
de sauvetage on a empli l'embarcation
d'eau pendant qu'elle était hackée pas
sur le fleuve pendant une intervention
c'est embarcation là juste une personne
qui se déplace ça devenait instable dans
un courriel Transport Canada l'organisme
fédéral qui régit les normes nous a
indiqué qu'il s'en remet au fabricants
et à l'opérateur pour être conforme s'il
prévoit effectuer des opérations
spéciales
cette embarcation qui sera ultimement
distribuée dans 8 cases nautiques à
Montréal a pourtant été présenté aux
pompiers en formation comme étant
insubmersible
force de constater que en effet le
bateau reste insubmersible mais n'est
pas un chavirable
l'incident qui disparaît mystérieusement
mais un certain point très peu de temps
après l'événement il y a commis un
balayage sous tapis
[Musique]
les pompiers de Montréal c'est une
organisation où la hiérarchie est
importante disons que les dénonciations
publiques sont pas très encouragés mais
avec la mort de Pierre Lacroix certains
ont décidé qu'il était temps de parler
Montréal est entouré d'eau et certains
secteurs comme les rapides de la Chine
sont plus hostiles que d'autres pour
mieux comprendre la puissance des eaux à
l'endroit où le pompier la croix a perdu
la vie il suffit de s'en approcher
c'est un bon régime sur le bateau qu'on
a deux moteurs qui ont quand même attiré
vers cet endroit-là si on peut imaginer
là que t'as pas de moteur tu as pas de
propulsion mais là tu es amené
directement
à cet endroit-là ici aussi le séma
continué d'utiliser les Hammerhead même
après le chavironnement de pointeau
tremble c'est pour cette raison qu'une
équipe de quatre pompiers il
pratiquaient des manœuvres le 25 mars
ils font leur dernier virage pour
revenir à leur point de départ puis là
il y a une panne de moteur ce pompier
bien au fait du dossier et qui ne veut
pas être identifié raconte comment le
chavironnement s'est produit subitement
peuvent pas accélérer ils peuvent pas
vider leur bateau par les tubulures à
l'arrière leur embarcation à ses mises à
vaciller côté babord du côté gauche puis
à faire une belle chandelle une belle
qui
c'est eux qui ont tout juste eu le temps
de sauter à l'eau sans comprendre ce qui
leur arrivait
à nouveau 4 hommes se retrouvent à la
mer mais cette fois dans les eaux
turbulentes des rapides de la Chine
c'est clairement
une situation d'urgence il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui ont été dépêchés
sur ça mais c'est clairement aussi un
paquet d'interrogations comment ça
pourquoi
ça aura pris ce deuxième chalièrement en
moins d'un an pour que le syndicat des
pompiers se disent sérieusement
préoccupé par la situation et revendique
de nouveaux bateaux ce qu'on a toujours
beaucoup entendu c'était la difficulté
de manœuvrer l'embarcation sur le plan
d'eau dans certaines conditions
de stabilité exacte ça nous préoccupait
à l'époque ça nous préoccupe toujours
aujourd'hui une des choses qui me
trouble le plus c'est tous les bateaux
de sauvetage tout bateau d'intervention
police Garde côtière ont toute
minimalement deux moteurs pour justement
que si il y en a un qui sortent étaient
à la merci du courant les Hamm ils ont
juste un moteur
plusieurs pompiers sont d'autant plus
préoccupés que les embarcations ont
régulièrement des problèmes en lien avec
le moteur ça faisait des semaines qu'on
les avait déjà on avait des
problématiques exemple
de ce qu'on appelle sensor donc une
pièce là électronique qui semble-t-il
faisait défaut puis le bateau n'avait
plus de pouvoir mais quand un bateau
urgence puis que seulement que un moteur
qui manque moi je me souviens d'un été
où est-ce que il y avait 6 des 8 bateaux
qui étaient en réparation à ce moment-là
il y avait clairement un problème on a
mis un seul moteur à l'intérieur de
l'embarcation mais vu le poids important
que ça crée il a fallu aller chercher un
moteur en Autriche ces moteurs là ben il
y avait personne qui était capable les
entretenir mécaniquement parlant c'était
une question de temps qui arrive un
accident avec ses bateaux là
est-ce que c'est ce qui s'est produit en
2021 rappelez-vous une panne de moteur
serait survenue avant le chavirment il
n'y a pas eu d'essai en 2010 mais le
chavirma a profondément marqué les
rescapés
ou être pris en charge si l'accident
existe pas qu'est-ce que vous voulez
dire si l'accident existe pas mais un
certain point très peu de temps après
l'événement il y a comme eu un balayage
sous tapis en effet au début de nos
recherches nous ne trouvons aucune trace
de cet événement malgré nos demandes
d'accès à l'information comme si le
chavironnement n'avait jamais eu lieu
le service d'incendie a produit son
rapport d'enquête interne mais
rapidement ce rapport-là il disparaît
il était quand même disponible puis un
moment donné plus suite autrement dit un
pompier qui veut s'informer pour savoir
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé puis éviter
que ça serait produire peut pas
consulter le rapport non rapport retirer
de la circulation
nous découvrons que de leur côté le BST
et la Commission des normes de l'équité
de la santé et de la sécurité du travail
ce sont intéressés à la faire la cness T
a notamment demandé au SIM de lui
communiquer son évaluation de la
formation et de la nécessité
d'intervenir dans les rapides de la
Chine étonnamment le BST lui décide de
ne pas faire d'enquête approfondie il a
été déterminé qu'il est peu probable de
tirer de nouvelles leçons de sécurité
suite à cet événement est-ce que le fait
qui est deux embarcations du même type
de la même organisation qui savait ne
devrait pas tirer une sonnette d'alarme
pour le BST c'est un choix qu'on doit
faire
contenu les ressources qu'on contenu les
conditions de chaque événement
après plusieurs semaines de recherche
une source nous achemine le fameux
rapport interne porté disparu
[Musique]
en lisant ça ce qu'on comprend c'est que
encore une fois l'estime rejette
l'hypothèse que c'est le bateau qui est
à l'origine de l'accident ils font
porter la responsabilité au personnel en
fait mais en viennent presque mot pour
mot à la même conclusion qu'en 2009
c'est à dire que c'est une erreur
humaine
l'incident est directement lié à une
erreur humaine et non aux mauvais
fonctionnement d'un élément de
l'embarcation
plus étonnant encore à travers des
dizaines de courriels entre chers
pompiers qui échangent sur les suites à
donner à cet accident on apprend que
sans tambour ni trompette le service de
sécurité incendie de Montréal décide de
créer une zone d'exclusion c'est-à-dire
une zone où les pompiers
n'interviendront carrément plus le bémol
c'est que 80% des gens qui font du
nautique qui font des sports nautiques
que ce soit du sol du kayak du kite
nommé il se retrouve dans cette zone là
puis nous comme pompier comme service
d'urgence on y met plus les pieds
[Musique]
juste ici c'est la zone d'exclusion ici
on peut naviguer donc là on est juste le
bord de la ligne la ligne est quelque
part avec quelque part ici est-ce que
est-ce qu'on est capable d'avoir la
ligne mais non
pour le plaisancier qui s'aventure sur
le fleuve sans savoir il n'y a aucune
indice de ce que c'est m'appelle la zone
d'exclusion à 8 km en amont en plein
milieu du fleuve seul s'est affiche
averti du danger mais rien pour indiquer
que les pompiers n'iront pas vous sauver
dans des rapides en théorie on ne
pourrait pas aller secourir quelqu'un
qui est juste ici l'autre côté à
quelques mètres
ils sont pourtant de plus en plus
nombreux à pratiquer des sports
nautiques en amont malgré la force du
courant qui pourrait les entraîner dans
les rapides et l'administration plante
encourage les citoyens à profiter du
fleuve j'espère que les Montréalistes
savent à quel point l'eau est important
pour nous c'est soit je pense qu'on
redéfinie ou on améliore le service à
population de ce côté-là ou bien il y a
des gens qui doivent être avisés de dire
n'allez pas là parce qu'il y a pas
personne qui va aller vous chercher
[Musique]
un malaise à la direction du Service des
incendies après la pause on vous révèle
un enregistrement secret
on est capable de faire des choses il
faut les faire de la bonne manière par
exemple avec les bons outils
[Musique]
les pompiers vont vous le dire ils sont
conditionnés pour sauver des vies alors
c'est complètement contre leur nature
quand on leur dit qu'ils doivent porter
secours aux gens sur le fleuve sauf dans
les endroits les plus dangereux
ce que vous entendez c'est une rencontre
avec des patrons du service de sécurité
incendie de Montréal enregistrée en 2014
à leur insu c'est une source
confidentielle qui nous a remis cet
enregistrement
contre des instructeurs nautiques
expriment clairement à la direction les
nombreux problèmes qui affectent le
sauvetage au cimes les mêmes problèmes
que plusieurs constats encore
aujourd'hui
les instructeurs remettent en question
la création de la zone d'exclusion qui
leur interdit d'intervenir dans les
rapides de la Chine
est capable de faire des choses il faut
les faire de la bonne manière par
exemple avec les bons outils et de
permettre aux gens de pouvoir y aller de
façon sécuritaire le directeur prend
acte de ses préoccupations
de malaise actuellement il y a une
question sans difficulté sur le
centenaire est-ce qu'on ne les
équipements
[Musique]
vous avez bien compris des doutes sur
les hammerheads et un malaise avec la
zone d'exclusion mais le Sim peut-il se
dégager de la responsabilité
d'intervenir dans les rapides
étonnamment oui parce que la première
responsable des sauvetages nautiques
autour de Montréal c'est la Garde
côtière les bateaux
ils sont où aucune idée on ne sait pas
dans la réalité selon Benoît Martel ce
n'est pas la garde côtière mais bien
plus souvent les pompiers du cime qui
interviennent sur le fleuve alors
qu'officiellement il ne devrait être
qu'en soutien ce qu'on peut prendre pour
acquis que parfois sont là des fois ils
sont pas mais non quand on l'appelle à
Montréal et les pompiers est-ce
questionne pas c'est un ordre de mission
donc on y va
mais aussi cette mission ne semble
claire pour personne y compris le
directeur en 2014
les instructeurs espérait beaucoup de
cette rencontre il souhaitait par
exemple de la formation spécialisée en
Eaux-Vives on ne signifie à maintes
reprises que les eaux ceintures en ligne
de Montréal c'est de l'eau vive on en a
parlé en 2013 on en a parlé avec Sylvain
losti aux alentours des années 2015 il
nous a dit de juste pas parler de pas
intégrer aucune notion écrite d'ovive
dans nos manuels parce que pour lui ça
n'existait pas l'eau vive à Montréal
a été responsable du nautique il sépare
la suite rendu presque au sommet de la
hiérarchie du cime il n'a pas voulu
répondre à nos questions
lui nous amusez dans le fond sur le tout
ce qui touchait l'eau vive les besoins
d'eau vive par rapport aux instructeurs
parce que ça coûtait des sous parce
qu'on doit former les pompiers en eau
vive la réponse est oui et c'est ce que
l'on réclame pourquoi l'employeur le
fait pas définitivement une question
d'argent c'est clair que la formation
est un des grands pas
qui est à défaut dans ce dossier là
vêtu une formation en eau vives
serait-il intervenue de la même façon en
est-ce qu'il se serait comporté de la
même façon après avoir chaviré ils se
sont retrouvés de longues minutes dans
les rapides de la Chine
à l'époque où il était responsable du
secteur nautique Benoît Martel misait
sur un plus petit nombre de pompiers
certifiés mais mieux formés
l'argumentateur dans tout ça c'était
moins on va avoir de monde plus on va
être capable de s'en occuper plus on va
être capable de les supporter plus ils
vont faire de pratique plus ils vont
avoir du millage donc ils vont être
meilleurs
mais le nombre de jours de formation n'a
cessé de diminuer et depuis la pandémie
le cime mise même sur l'autoformation en
ligne en 2009 la formation est à
d'environ 8 jours aujourd'hui avec
l'avènement de l'autoformation le
pompier se prépare en caserne
le nombre de jours que ça prendra pour
se sentir à l'aise pour aller passer les
épreuves donc si il dit c'est une
journée c'est une journée exacte c'est
sûr que c'est sûrement plus qu'une
journée mais trois journées de ta
formation pour moi de valent rien c'est
de l'autoformation on est bien loin de
la formation pour le sauvetage donné par
la Garde côtière une formation de 16
jours de faire ça tout seul
officier de la garde côtière spécialisé
en sauvetage nautique lorsqu'on est dans
un opération de recherche chauffage
de me l'expliquer s'il n'est pas capable
de me l'expliquer mon revient
donc c'est en fait critique et essentiel
d'avoir un formateur qui est capable
d'analyser l'apprentissage
c'est tout à fait la base
après la mort de Pierre Lacroix le cime
a mis sur pied un comité qui doit
réévaluer ce qu'il appelle l'offre
nautique pour se faire à qui le Sims se
fit-il à nouveau à Sylvain Ricard à qui
on a confié la direction de ce comité
maintenant retraitée il a accepté un
contrat pour l'occasion
j'imagine que vous entendez comme moi
les pompiers qui disent que la formation
est insuffisante c'est impossible que
vous l'entendiez pas
pourquoi
dites-moi pourquoi est-ce qu'elle est
insuffisante
il y a pas l'embarcation parce que les
Hammerhead sont brisés
[Musique]
mais c'est un problème ça
ben oui 25
quelques jours après cet entretien la
participation de Sylvain Ricard au
comité de refonte du nautique a pris fin
donc est-ce que c'était le bon bateau
cette question il semble que le
directeur du Sims se la pose désormais
lui aussi confronté au fait de notre
reportage alors qu'il les avait toujours
défendu changement de cap le directeur
ordonne le retrait immédiat de tous les
Hammerhead en service pour la suite le
film mise sur 12 embarcations de type
Titan acquis pour la somme de 7 millions
de dollars comme l'explique le directeur
dans une vidéo récemment mise en ligne
ces embarcations d'une conception
ultime en matière de stabilité et de
sécurité ont commencé à arriver à
Montréal cet été et la formation est
déjà commencé je pense que ça va être
comme de dire je conduisais une civique
là je vois conduire une formule 1 ça va
demander un niveau de formation qui va
être ajusté à ça
le seum comme la Garde côtière a refusé
notre demande d'entrevue invoquant
notamment une enquête publique de la
coronaire pour ce reportage nous avons
aussi joint plusieurs chefs directeurs
et membres de l'état-major actif ou
retraités montrer du doigt par nos
sources aucun d'entre eux ne s'estimait
imputable
[Musique]
le soir de 17 octobre 2021 dans le noir
dans l'urgence les pompiers abordent du
18 64 sont sans aucun doute entrer dans
la zone d'exclusion plusieurs de nos
sources craignent que ce soit eux qui
soient montrés du doigt que ce soit eux
qui comme par le passé porte la
responsabilité de l'erreur humaine
pourquoi la première fois c'était pas
suffisant pour dire plus jamais
on se retrouve 12 ans plus tard tout est
identique sont fait victimes là il y a
eu un décès plus d'autres victimes la
colère la Colère vient de là
assez stacée j'aimerais ça que quand tu
arrives à un échec un accident qu'on
puisse s'en servir pour grandir puis
devenir meilleur et non pas toujours
essayer de trouver un coupable on le
savait que le bateau est dangereux
on savait qui manquait de formation on a
réagi en mettant une ligne imaginaire
dans des GPS je connais pas de pompiers
à Montréal Pont Pierre qui réside moi
j'arrête à la ligne
ces deux personnes là sont dans le
bateau ils passeront un rapide puis si
on ne change on les récupère de l'autre
bord on connais pas
le jour des funérailles le directeur du
système riche en limite vient me serrer
la main puis je l'ai regardé dans les
yeux puis je lui ai dit
honnêtement sa main toute seule en ce
moment ça devrait pas arriver
parce que il y a des choses qui doivent
changer pour qu'il y ait d'autres
enfants comme moi qui perdent pas leur
papa
après la pause d'importants revirements
avant la diffusion de notre enquête
nous avons pris la décision
Julie qu'on entend là les pompiers de
Montréal ont pas vu ça souvent
westination vraiment exceptionnelle
Marie Maude le grand patron du Sim le
directeur Richard Liman qui prend le
micro et qui s'adresse aux pompiers dans
toutes les casernes de la ville pour
leur parler et leur annoncer en fait le
retrait des fameux Hammerhead les
bateaux donc qui sont au cœur de la
controverse ça se passait la semaine
dernière à quelques jours en fait de la
diffusion de notre partage et il leur a
d'ailleurs expliqué que c'était dans le
contexte de la préparation de notre
reportage que cette décision là a été
prise par mesure de précaution mais
plusieurs pompiers nous ont raconté
marie-maure dont ceux qui ont enregistré
cette cette prise de parole là du
directeur que c'était jamais vu que ce
souvenait pas d'avoir entendu parler un
directeur comme ça assez troupes pas
même pour la mort du pompier Pierre
Lacroix et par la suite la Ville de
Montréal que pris connaissance du
retrait de ces bateaux là a annoncé à
son tour qu'elle ouvrait une enquête
interne donc pour faire la lumière sur
cette situation là elle venait de
prendre connaissance et parlant de la
ville il y a de nouveaux développements
encore ce matin à quelques heures de la
diffusion du reportage oui parce que la
Commission des normes de sécurité du
travail la cnst a annoncé ce matin les
conclusions de son enquête qu'elle
menait depuis presque un an maintenant
plusieurs de conclusions se retrouvent
dans notre reportage en fait elle voit
des problèmes avec les embarcations pas
des problèmes avec la formation entre
autre chose et surtout Marie-Maude elle
met la Ville de Montréal à la mande il y
aura une contravention d'une somme de
10000 ou 17000 en fait à 70
000 dollars parce que la ville dit-elle
à sérieusement compromis la sécurité et
l'intégrité de ces travailleurs
maintenant il est trop tôt pour porter
des conclusions mais nous irons au fond
de cette affaire alors la ville a une
trentaine de jours pour contester
décider et annoncer si elle plaidera
coupable ou non à cette contravention là
pour la suite des choses on ne sait pas
ce qu'il va devenir des EM est-ce
qu'elles vont être gardées est-ce qu'on
va les retirer pour de bon qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire avec la formation pour ça
la Ville de Montréal a décidé qu'elle
attendait l'enquête publique sera menée
par la coronaire Jean camel qui va
commencer elle au mois de novembre
prochain en tout cas l'objectif de vous
lanceurs d'alerte des pompiers qui vous
ont transmis de l'information et atteint
ils ont été entendre je le pense merci
beaucoup Julie je vous en prie c'est
comme ça que se termine notre émission
de ce soir au nom de toute l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là je vous
donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]